before we continue I'd like to give a
shout out to the sponsors of this video
crossing void crossing voids an anime
turn-based RPG with more than 50 most
loved characters from 25 plus anime
franchises such as Sao a certain magical
index and many more and guess what their
skills in the anime are the same in game
with skills such as kirito's star burst
stream and Makoto's railgun you can mix
and match and discover cross skills
between characters crossing void also
has an all-new storyline with full voice
overs when they say adventures end game
was the most ambitious crossover ever
they've never seen crossing void in
their crossing waifu's pre-registration
is now open on the iOS App Store and
Google Play so if you're interested in
the game check out the link in the
description how long has it been since
the Issyk eyes chandra take over the
anime world I've honestly lost track if
I like a slow but steady invasion you
start seeing shows in this genre seep
into seasonal lists and then you realize
there's five of them airing in one
season the genre has a lot of gems but
many of the shows have become seasonal
filler plagued by low effort adaptations
and general apathy from the fanbase much
like the infinite stratos like battle
harems were roughly half a decade ago
understandably much of this stuff
doesn't have anime adaptations Studios
want to play it safe with adapting the
harmless choices you either go Opie main
character that gets a harem in a
medieval s world like re faretta
and probably half that starts being
adapted to be honest or something less
serious and overblown in terms of comedy
like chrono Suba now we won't spend much
time with these on the list because what
we'll be talking about a 10 series that
would likely make someone question
japan's sanity although it's probably
not the first time anyone's done that
with anime before let's get started we
start off with the upcoming anime kemon
ami cheap from the same artist that
brought us the wildly entertaining
connoisseur manga comes this next issue
Kai that looks to break the mold as
countless titles have tried before this
time I lucky recipient of a ticket to
another world is professional wrestler
Shabbat again Zog on his arrival he gets
a simple request from a princess
eliminate evil magical beasts too bad
for her though our protagonists an
animal lover who lets this take
precedence over a spoiled princesses
wishes
a suplex later and bam ienzo gets a new
goal in the world but his love of
animals to good use by opening a pet
shop featuring the monsters in this
world who look exactly like creatures
from a furries dream fantasy this anime
comes out in fall 2019 we can pass the
weird premise it looks genuinely funny I
mean it might not be a blockbuster in a
jam-packed full 2019 season but it could
be a nice show for you to unwind with
once in a while next we have Dragonball
the time I got reincarnated as Yamcha
ever imagine what it'd be like to be
reincarnated as a character from your
favorite manga well here's a series for
you our protagonist a young fan of
Dragonball gets killed and is
reincarnated into the world of Dragon
Ball now that sounds like a dream come
true right there's just one problem out
of all of the possible choices he's
reincarnated as the series trademark
loser
Yamcha all hope isn't lost though for
this version of Yamcha actually carries
knowledge of what's going to happen in
the series so using this knowledge the
new yump sure looks to change the future
going from the weakest to the strongest
they it sounds like a job for your
everyday otaku the manga is actually
very short and can be read and shown in
jumped digital magazine so if you're
interested go and check it out ASAP
about my room leads to dungeon is the
number eight entry on the list
starring high school dropout thorugh
Suzuki the story begins when he stays in
a cheap apartment in Tokyo after all who
could say no to a monthly rent of three
thousand yen I know I would him but
these things obviously have strings
attached
no the room isn't a haunted or anything
like that but it does have a nifty
feature being connected to a dungeon
after saving a female knight thora
realizes his home has another purpose in
addition to housing him a rest stop for
adventurers exploring the dungeon looks
like a peaceful life for our protagonist
is nowhere in sight so instead Lackey
misadventures with residents of another
world are on the menu technically
speaking the series is anticipated but
it doesn't feature the traditional setup
of the protagonist dying than being
reincarnated or getting waltzed off to
another world somehow the premise
reminds me of invaders of the Roku juma
which means it's not as weird as some of
the titles that we'll be seeing soon
being like invaders is also a good thing
in my opinion I found it really
entertaining and we need more Issyk I
along the veins of that series will be
proceeding with an
may still fresh on our minds at number
seven okasan online I'm sure a lot of
you who are updated with seasonal anime
know about this show
long story short it's about a boy who
gets transported into a game world
setting with his mom after answering a
survey the catch luck has it that his
mom has beat him in terms of power yep
it's the supposed main character's
mother who becomes the overpowered a
Sakai MC with that the mother and son
duo begin traveling this strange world
and yes the series is filled with incest
subtext it doesn't get any more Japanese
than that with their seeming love for
incest if the horde of thirsty Emoto
shows is any indication to go by touring
a magical world with your mom never
seems so fun before did it right thanks
to its parodying nature and the
intentionally provocative set up the
show garnered a lot of interest even
back when it was still a novel as an
anime the memes are there for sure if
this series in particular seems a bit
tame to you let me reassure you that
things will only get weirder from here
on out the beast and his pet high school
girl takes the number 6 spot on the list
the plot of the beast and his pet high
school girl is self-explanatory
Kashiwagi aki gets kidnapped and before
she knows it she wakes up in a strange
world filled with intelligent and
anthropomorphic animals in this world
the animals take the place of humans as
the dominant species and aki ends up in
a pet store
xenovia Wolfman quickly takes a liking
to her and buys her thus beginning her
new strange life why do I think I've
heard this somewhere before while many
people would initially dismiss the story
as furry bait it has some legitimately
nice things going for it the story has
some cute moments and for those who are
still quite apprehensive you don't have
to worry about any major furry romance
or itchy things commonly associated with
these weird Japanese things past halfway
onto the list now and we enter uncanny
territory starting with reincarnated as
the strongest wand in another world I'm
forcing a girl to be a magical girl
against her will oh boy here we go with
the insanely long titles and the insane
storylines that scream Japan now we're
talking
alright this series introduces us to
Namir AG an avid fan of the magic
girl series charming Laluna as per is a
chi drill truck hoon comes in and kicks
off the story killing our protagonist
and sending him packing to another world
opening his eyes nimmy finds himself in
a world of magic not as a magical girl
mind you as of wand with unlimited magic
power at your disposal what else do you
want
unfortunately ones are useless without
wielders and a girl just happens to be
passing by seeing the girl as this
world's equivalent of la luna Nimmi
begins the quest of turning her into a
full-fledged magical girl let this adore
edie mangas premise speak for itself and
trust me we ain't seen nothing yet not
with the next ones on this list fourth
on the list is that time I go
reincarnated as a dragon egg just
kidding the actual title is reincarnated
as a dragon egg let's aim to be the
strongest has the idea of being
reincarnated as a dragon egg ever
crossed your mind don't lie then again
no anime watch her from before October
2018 really thought the reincarnating
into slime was possible either
well the protagonist of this story wakes
up in a game world complete with status
bars and the like yep I can imagine the
rolling eyes so just stay with me for a
second okay our heroes roll a half
hatched dragon egg using his wits from
when he was a human he must survive this
unforgiving world filled with monsters
that just want to kill him the quest to
defeat the monsters and eventually
involved into a majestic dragon begins
now the series starts off slow but once
you get past the early slugs the plot
twists are rather interesting sit back
and watch our protagonist evolution into
the strongest dragon in the world as we
start counting down our top three we
have a ride on king how does
earthbending Putin riding a dragon sound
I bet you didn't know a series like this
existed I did you our Putin look-alike
is Alexander Putin of ruler of Persia
violence reigns supreme in the country
but that's expected when your leader is
obsessed with dominating everything by
riding them both literally and
figuratively an incident not completely
brought about by notorious truck hoon
then sends him to an unknown world full
of magical creatures what else is there
for the manly leader of Persia to do
than to start dominating them I have no
words for this this is wild
then he gets joined by more denizens of
the world and wait a minute properly
armored and dressed women a burly main
character who spent so much time
shirtless the tables have turned
fanservice in second place we take a
look at reborn as a vending machine I
now wonder the dungeon insanely long
title ludicrous premise and a light
novel that was published on the
now-infamous website sounds just about
right
this is the story of a vending machine
otaku those exist that dies by getting
crushed by what else a vending machine
as if Sakai has taught us dying on earth
isn't the end
so he gets reincarnated in a fantasy
world unfortunately luckily I suppose
he's reincarnated as a sentient vending
machine stock vending machine powers
include a very limited vocabulary the
ability to dispense all sorts of things
he bought from his previous life and the
ability to upgrade and load himself with
powers a meeting with lamis a hunter
girl who names him Bach so formally
begins the duo's adventure through this
fantastic world did you get that for the
word premise and all this story is good
as a unique if not strange take on Issyk
ID as the positive comments of feedback
have said the weird premise is there to
catch the attention of viewers but it's
the story and engaging writing that will
make sure that they stay and stay they
did number one on the list is I was
reincarnated as a hot spring in an
alternative world what a mouthful of a
title you thought that getting
reincarnated as a vending machine was
weird try this one out for size the
story goes that our protagonist Itami
Kusatsu dies on his way to a hot spring
you know the istic i drilled by now
right and at this point i don't have to
repeat it a hero gets a second chance of
life this time as a hot spring that's
right I'm not kidding our protagonist
dies and literally becomes a hot spring
naturally as a hot spring he then
experiences the joy of having beautiful
adventurers take a dip inside him for a
regen
2bath why do I get the feeling that this
premise sounds a lot more suggestive
than it should be anyone else feel the
same way oh well
perfect situation for fanservice amazing
simply amazing Japan love you guys so
next time you get sick of things like
shield hero slime and Death March
perhaps some of these titles repeats
your liking or not let's just say that
the possibilities are limitless in
it'sso KY which is probably why the John
was so popular in the Land of the Rising
Sun on another note most of the stuff
here isn't likely to get adapted into
anime for obvious reasons so if you want
a chance to see what crazy ideas Japan
has for you you better start reading
them as manga or novels so what's the
weirdest it's a KY you've ever read
comment below and let me know don't
forget to check out our sponsors game
crossing void the ultimate anime
crossover with characters from some of
the most famous anime zucchini out to
rule the reader roll the Gacha to
collect and upgrade your favorite
characters making them stronger and
fiercer why flowing up and enhancing
your intimacy with the character lets
you receive unlockables such as
exclusive illustrations and voice
recordings there are more rewards to be
given out with crossing voids Facebook
and Twitter community events so be sure
to follow their social media accounts to
keep up with the prizes I definitely
recommend you to check out the game epic
battles with stunning animations and a
fully voiced cast by the original
Japanese voice actors are waiting
pre-registration is now open for
crossing void on the iOS App Store and
Google Play so come on what you waiting
for click that link in the description
right now I'll see you next time on
video
[Music]